Morning everyone. Quick standup — let's keep it to 15 minutes. Who wants to go first?
I'll go. Yesterday I finished the database schema migration for the transcript segments table. The FTS5 virtual table is set up and the sync triggers are working. I ran a test insert and the search index is being populated correctly.
Nice, Tom. Any blockers?
One thing — I noticed the DELETE trigger pattern in the documentation uses a regular DELETE statement, but for external content FTS5 tables, you actually need to use the special insert-with-delete command. I fixed it in our codebase but worth flagging for the team.
Good catch. Can you update the migration docs so future engineers know about that gotcha?
Already done. Added a comment block in the migration file.
I'll go next. I'm working on the repository layer. The BaseRepository with generic CRUD is mostly done. Today I'm implementing the MeetingRepository filter and pagination logic — the complex query with participant join.
How's the async session setup going? Any issues with the SQLAlchemy 2.x async patterns?
It's cleaner than I expected. The key thing is making sure every repository method uses AsyncSession and awaits the execute calls. The main footgun is accidentally using the sync Session instead of AsyncSession in FastAPI routes — that causes a greenlet error at runtime.
Yeah, I hit that yesterday. Took me an hour to debug. The error message is pretty cryptic.
Should we add a type check or a lint rule to catch that?
I'll add a type annotation check to the CI pipeline. If any function signature shows db: Session instead of db: AsyncSession, the build fails.
My turn. Yesterday I set up the seed data framework. I have three of the five meetings seeded with realistic transcripts. The main challenge was getting the speaker labels consistent between the participants table and the transcript segments.
How did you solve that?
I defined a speaker roster as a Python dataclass at the top of each meeting's seed block. The same objects are used when creating participants and when creating transcript segments. So the speaker_name in the segments always matches the name in participants.
Smart. That consistency is critical for the speaker color assignment to work correctly on the frontend.
Exactly. Today I'm finishing the last two meetings and making sure the date distribution is correct — we need some meetings this week, last week, and last month so the date filters are testable.
Anything blocking?
Just waiting for the sample audio file to be committed so I can verify the transcript timestamps don't exceed the audio duration. Can someone get that done today?
I'll handle that this morning. I'll find a royalty-free 15-minute MP3 and commit it to the frontend public folder.
Good. I'll also double check that all the seeded meetings have audio_url set to the correct path.
Great. Wrap up — Tom is on FTS triggers and docs, Aisha is on repository layer and CI lint rule, Marcus is finishing seed data. I'm committing the audio file. Any blockers? No? See you tomorrow.